It's your anniversary?
With her?
You're straight?
Fuck off.
Are you? With that tote bag?
Thank you for participating
in this lovely
social experiment.
…so welcome
to Netflix: I Like to Watch!
We're here, we're queer.
Let's go, baby.
-Hi, bitches.
-Oh, bitch.
How are you?
Having these spaces
and these venues, like,
people seem
to take it for granted
when the reality
of the situation is…
Think about
how many queer venues,
even before the lockdown,
were closing
and shutting down
and just couldn't fund
themselves.
Without those spaces,
this show doesn't exist.
That platform doesn't exist.
You don't have
the entertainment
and you don't have
the safe spaces
that we all need.
It's Netflix UK's
I Like to Watch
with none other than
the delicious The Vivienne
and the beautiful
Blu Hydrangea!
-One, two, three!
-Whoo!
Drag kings are
at the forefront
of the radical nature
of drag.
But drag in and of itself
is, like, a radical,
political act, right?
And just at Stonewall
when it was
a trans woman at the front
and lesbians
that were, like, very key,
again,
people have been sidelined.
And I think
we shouldn't forget
that there's
an entire community of drag
that we're not seeing
represented
in the mainstream media.
Keep supporting drag
queens.
Keep supporting
the divas of the dance.
Just because a queen
hasn't been on Drag Race
doesn't mean they're less
valid than anybody else.
Just check that…
-You look beautiful there.
-Oh, fab.
Just some…
That's just working.
Well, here we are,
back on the road,
back on tour,
back out with the girls.
I'm so excited. I'm really,
actually buzzing.
And it's not just, like,
any old show.
We're just sitting,
watching some good telly
and some good movies,
and just having
a good old bitch, really.
Yes.
I did horse riding lessons
as a child.
-Poor horse.
-And I kid you not…
Go on, tell me.
I want to hear the story.
I'm still, like,
finding my feet
touring and travelling
post-"panny-dem".
Like, I've just been missing
human contact
and interactions and people.
If I could summarise Chez's
vision when it comes
to a garment,
it's literally
feathers, rhinestones
and a hope and a dream.
And don't ask me to make it,
because we all know
how that turns out.
One of the double edges
of the Drag Race sword
is that, you know,
people expect drag queens to
look like supermodels now,
and that is
very far from the truth.
You know, some of the best
queens in the country…
Miss Jason,
I mean,
she won't mind me saying,
she looks like your nan.
But we will have
the best night ever
watching Miss Jason
in a bar in Brighton
than you maybe would
somebody who is
painted immaculately,
who's never been
on stage in their life.
I don't care what you look
like as a drag queen.
I would rather go and watch
a 60-year-old fella
in a bin bag
with blue eyeshadow
up to his eyebrows.
As long
as they're entertaining,
I couldn't give a shit.
I like to look nice.
But for me, that's not the
be-all and end-all of drag.
When I go shopping,
I tend to get stuff
for me out of drag.
So, like, really look after
the person
that's behind the mask.
People often don't see
that side.
And for me, I'm not very
much a character in drag.
I'm just, like, me
with an IV of Red Bull.
So, like,
I'm still the same person.
But I also forget
that you are allowed
to look out for yourself.
And I used to feel
tremendous guilt
every time I treated myself
to something out of drag,
because I'm, like,
"This is money
that you should be putting
back into your work."
And it's, like,
actually, hold a second.
You can treat yourself.
Make some noise
for Cheryl Hole!
Very excited for tonight.
I can't wait.
Been building it up
all week.
It's, like,
"Ooh, it's nearly here."
And I haven't seen
The Vivienne
since before
she went on Ru Paul.
That was the last time
she was here,
just when it was announced.
Thank you, Duncan.
I'm not paying for that.
I'm gonna pop this here.
A big thank you
to Duncan as well.
He's the landlord.
Give it up for Sundowners.
I'm Duncan Bayles
and I own Sundowners.
It's the only LGBTQ bar
in Margate
and for
quite an area around.
Well, before I had this,
I was digging worms
on the beach.
And the opportunity come up
to borrow some money
and have a change of career.
I think you can
probably mention his name
to any of the bars,
restaurants around here
and they know exactly
who you're talking about.
He is the kind of
beating heart of Sundowners
behind it all
and the true
kind of personality
that you kind of need,
not just the LGBT community
really locally.
I think, kind of,
everyone sees Sundowners
as a kind of friendly local
kind of place.
Anyone and everyone
kind of just comes in,
has a drink
and can socialise
with whoever they want.
I felt through lockdown
there was times
when I didn't know
whether I wanted to carry on
or whether to walk away,
with what you're running up
in debts.
It's, like,
how do you make it work?
Because the trouble is,
you didn't know how long
it was gonna go on for.
We were closed in,
what was it, November 6th?
And we was told
it was four weeks,
and we didn't reopen
until the 12th April.
No one knew what
the future was gonna hold.
They were, "We don't know
how we'll pay our bills.
We don't know
how we'll do this, do that."
But we're not London.
We haven't got a big scene
with money and that,
you know.
If you were in London,
some of
the big bars there got
Arts Council funding
and stuff
that as a small, provincial
LGBT bar, we didn't get.
With the amount of people
that have said since,
they were so worried
that we wouldn't survive
and they would have
nowhere to go after,
and that makes you realise
just how important you are
to the community.
The first night
we opened in July,
just to see people
being able to dance again.
We'd spent all summer
telling people to sit down
every time they got up
to try and dance,
and to actually see people
get up and dance again
and hug each other,
I think… yeah, it turned
out it was quite amazing.
Quite emotional
in one way, that…
And people were.
Margate, are you ready?
Yeah, I think we'll still be
here for a few more years.
Can't afford to retire now.
My God, look at Miles!
For a lot of drag queens,
it's the place
where they come into being.
Um, it's the place
where you first discover
aspects about yourself.
It's where you find
your freedom.
Um, they really are
the places where you can
start to explore
and play with identity,
but also start to explore
and play with creativity.
And it's through
that nexus of relationships
you find in smaller bars
that amazing things
are allowed to grow.
And I think it's the…
We all think of drag
in the big lights
and in the big cities.
And I think the truth is,
to create really,
really interesting drag,
it has to be enmeshed
in that
kind of almost familial
community relationships.
It takes a lot of love
to grow fabulous.
Now, can I just remind
you all he is 12 years old.
So, where's his…
Where's your mum?
Can I just say,
he is fabulous.
Thank you so much
for being an amazing parent,
because the world needs
more allies.
Honest to God.
There are children
and young trans people
and loads of people
from our community
who are getting ostracised
from their family
every single day.
And for you to be such an
amazing, supportive parent
is really amazing,
so thank you.
Miles has school tomorrow,
everybody.
Have you got school?
Oh, fuck off.
Can he call in sick?
Oh, the history
of the New Foresters
is absolutely amazing.
It's, um, the oldest gay bar
in Nottingham,
going back to 1938.
Which is fantastic to find
that they've found evidence
of gay people
coming into here.
A couple of weeks ago,
we had a marquee
outside in the car park,
because of the Covid.
And I was watching over
the marquee
and I saw
this young lad crying.
He was only about 18, 19.
And I saw all his friends,
all male friends,
round him
with their arms round him.
Now, I'm a landlady
who will go and communicate
with my customers
and make sure
that they're OK.
So, I could see
that he wasn't very happy,
I thought.
So I went over
and basically asked him
and his mate says to me,
"Do you know something?
Because you've provided
this safe place,
he's just come out
to all his workmates."
And I've got no children,
so I was really proud.
You know, I just thought,
you know,
we've… we've provided that.
And I thought
that was amazing.
That's the whole reason,
isn't it,
of us being here.
Well, I moved to Liverpool
when I was 16.
And I was working behind
a bar at 16, illegally.
Um…
But it was
those queer venues
that Vivienne was born.
You know, when you're young
and you come out,
and you feel…
You know, a lot of people
are kicked out at home,
so they've got
no family to turn to.
So the fact that they
can come to places like this
and realise that,
"Oh, my God,
I'm actually gonna be fine.
All right, my family
have kicked me out,
but I've just found
a huge family,
globally, that are always
gonna have my back."
Nottingham!
Happy birthday…
To you
-Oh!
-Happy birthday
To you
Happy birthday…
It's a shit caterpillar
from Asda!
…dear Tia
-This hair is flammable.
-Watch your hair.
Happy birthday to you!
For health
and safety reasons…
-Come on, blow it!
-Blow! Blow it!
Aw, look at that.
I went to uni in Nottingham
and lived here
for five years,
so, uh, it's got a massive,
massive place in my heart
and I'm really excited
to be back.
We are about to go into
the Nottingham New Theatre,
which is the only
student-run theatre
in England,
thank you very much.
I love it, it's
where I spent all my time
and learned all about,
sort of, performance
and things like that.
So, it's kind of had
a big impact on my life now
and my drag.
Wake up in the morning
Thinking we need more
We need more space
We need more storage
We need more support
We need events
To make societies
Open for all
Whether you live
On Sutton Bonington
Or in Sherwood Hall
I'm talking about…
-Hello.
-Hi there. Big hug.
-Lovely to meet you.
-Mucho. I'm Tia.
I'm the president
of the NNT currently.
Oh, lovely. That's nice.
You're the Lawrence Chaney
of the New Theatre?
-That's great.
-Thank you.
What, from your experience
of the NNT,
have you kind of carried
forward with you into drag?
Well,
I actually started drag
because I put on a musical
where there was
a drag role in it.
Amazing.
And then I decided
I wanted to do that show,
to put it on myself
in London,
cast myself in the role,
um, and then
someone just said
that I should start doing it
and enter a competition.
And then fast-forward
however many years,
and Drag Race and all of
that kind of thing.
Oh, but this is
the best moment.
It's like all-singing,
all-dancing Eurovision
with actual
Eurovision contestants.
This is like…
my full idea of heaven.
I'm doing fine
All the things that I wanna…
-Welcome back.
-Oh, my goodness.
-That's a separate room.
-I know.
It was only, like,
this bit before.
Oh, this is great.
It's very well organised.
OK, I'm not kidding.
I fully… This… That's why
I wanted to go in here.
I fully wrote my name
on one of these.
-And you've still got it.
-We've still got it.
We never throw
anything away.
That's actually so mad.
I was, like, thinking
you must have
got rid of it by now.
But literally,
when I was leaving,
it was the last thing
that I did,
was write my name on this.
That's literally,
like, eight years ago.
That's so funny.
I'm absolutely gonna have
to take a photo of it
and send it to my friends.
I know that's really sad,
because it's, like,
a lighting fixture.
But, like,
they were literally
my whole life
while I was here.
That's really cute.
That's made me so happy.
I think,
in my day-to-day life,
it can be very difficult
to sort of, like, maintain
that level of, like,
positivity and, like,
joy within myself,
because, like, everyone has
struggles and difficulties,
especially
off the back of,
like, the lockdown
and everything
that we've gone through.
Like, I think people are
massively underestimating
the mental health impact of,
like, the global pandemic
and everything
that's happened.
It's something
I really struggle with.
I get so nervous
before I go on stage.
I get really worried
that everyone's gonna think
that I look bad or sound bad
or all of
that kind of thing.
And, like,
it's easy for people
to say, like, "Oh whatever,
I do this, like, for me,"
and, like,
"My life is my own."
But also, like,
I absolutely don't.
Like, the reason why I do
drag is to entertain people.
So if I feel
like I'm bad at that,
that's gonna cause me,
like, massive insecurity.
But I think, like,
the thing
that's been amazing for me
off the back of the show
is, like, getting this,
like, overwhelming
outpouring
of, like, love and so many
uplifting comments,
and things like that.
It has made me feel
so much more self-assured
and given me
the ability to, like,
give that back to others.
So this is probably
a little bit different
to how you remember.
-I mean, it's tidy…
-Well, yeah.
-…which is nice.
-Thank you very much.
It's really weird looking
at all these costumes
because, obviously,
costumes are
a massive part of my job,
especially preparing
for Drag Race.
You have to spend
a lot of time,
and a lot of money,
on, um, outfits
that the judges may
or may not enjoy.
So, um, I wish I'd just come
back to the New Theatre,
to be honest.
Just nabbed a few things?
I could have worn a
football shirt, like Bimini
in the first episode.
Um, I think UK drag
has definitely changed
in the last few years.
I feel like everyone,
sort of, leaned in more to…
I say everyone, I dressed
as an ice-cream cone.
I think a lot of people
have leaned more into the
fashion aspect of things.
I mean, like,
my drag mothers
and stuff like that are all
much more traditional,
sort of British
cabaret,
uh, vibes.
I think if I could change
one thing about drag
in the UK in 2021,
I'd just wish people were
a bit funnier.
Do you know what I mean?
Death drops
aren't hilarious.
Do you know what is?
A 55-year-old
with shit blue makeup,
telling jokes on stage.
Great. Love that.
My hometown
I think
one of the frustrating
things that I see in drag
is the way that we are
sometimes held up
as these
perfect images of beauty.
And we're expected to be
these perfect images
of beauty
and ambassadors
of the beauty industry.
And for me,
the real magic of drag
is the disruption
of the very idea
that something,
or one particular look,
is beautiful.
I always say, the most
magical thing about drag
is taking it off.
And I'm very serious
about that.
Because
what makes drag special
and distinct from
other kinds of celebrity
is the duality of it.
You, as an audience member,
understand
that there is another me
behind this.
We show you
that there is another me.
You know that this
presentation I'm making,
whilst it is utterly
a truthful expression
of something
that I am feeling,
it is ultimately fake.
You know
that I take all this off
at the end of the day.
And if you know
that I do that
and I can be given praise
for looking either, whether
it's spectacularly beautiful
or weird or ugly or strange,
then you know
that none of that stuff
really matters, right?
It's actually OK for you
to not worry
about the way that you look,
walking down the street.
So I think
it frustrates me sometimes
when people treat drag
as a new beauty craze
rather than
the end of beauty crazes.
Scotland is always
the underdog in the UK.
I think people don't take us
that seriously.
They don't kind of think
that we have drag.
I think people are amazed
when they find out there is
drag here, in Scotland.
But the drag scene
here's incredible.
And I think it's so amazing
that we now have
the confirmation of that
through a Drag Race winner
in Lawrence Chaney
who is someone
who started drag here, in…
in, um, Scotland
and rose through the scene,
became top of the scene
and then won Drag Race.
Testing, testing. Mic check.
One, two, one, two.
Three, four, five.
Six, seven, eight.
Nine, ten.
I think we're good.
The Polo Lounge has been
around for, I think,
30-odd years
here in Glasgow.
It's this gorgeous,
huge building,
right in the Merchant City
and when I started coming
out in the queer scene
when I turned 18,
I would come here,
because it was
the most well-known club.
I think it's time
we have a nosey round,
don't you?
Let's go. Come on.
Oh, my God.
That's right, bitches.
It's you, it's me, it's us,
and we're back.
We are here in Club X
at the Polo Lounge.
And baby…
You like what you see?
You want to get whipped?
You want to get spanked?
Well, honey, you can get
all of that here.
But let's do
a little tour du jour
and have a good time.
Follow me.
Right over here,
I really don't know
what's happening, but…
Oh!
I don't know what's
happening to be honest,
but I'm getting
a kind of, like…
shoe-shine-y, foot fetish,
licking toe jam
kind of vibe.
Right. Now.
If you look down
about ankle level,
you will see
a big slab of wood.
And I'm gonna
walk it for you.
Are you ready? Here we go.
Drink in hand and all,
because she's what?
A professional.
And then we take it
down to the cage.
Oh yes, baby. That's right.
You wanna get in?
You want to get locked up?
You want me to throw away
the key, maybe swallow it?
I could do
for a price.
But mama,
this is
Club X
at the Polo Lounge.
Be here, be queer,
and if you're lucky,
I might come around
and spank you some time.
Yeah.
I think the best part
about Polo is
when you come here, you can
be who you want to be.
Like, you don't have
to kind of hide anything.
So if you want to come here
and you want to wear
all leather, for example,
no one's gonna judge you.
If you want
to come here in drag,
no one's gonna judge you.
Um, if you want to come here
and wear no top,
no one's gonna judge you.
So it's…
You can just be yourself.
It's you, it's me, it's us,
it's Tia Kofi, it's Netflix,
it's I Like to Watch, bitch.
I think, before lockdown,
what was the queer scene
like in Glasgow?
It was
very white male orientated,
I believe.
Um, even here in Polo
it was very like that, um…
A lot of, like,
the advertisement stuff
was more pushed towards
sort of white, gay men.
And I feel,
having 16 months off,
we really
thought about it more.
We sat and had chats.
"How can we
make this more accepting?"
And then we brought in
the whole idea of, like,
well why is it just gay men?
Let's make it just queer.
It's an umbrella term.
It's an inclusive term.
You're gonna see things
in here
that you may not see
in straight venues,
and you're gonna realise
that actually, the gay
community is made up
of loads
of tiny little things,
and it's not just these
set-in-stone,
what you see
throughout the years, on TV.
The future
of Scottish drag is…
I hope, personally,
it's gonna be more accepting
for
more AFAB queens.
Definitely it's come in,
um, and more drag kings.
That's what we're missing
a lot of here.
It's doesn't just have to be
men dressed as women.
That's…
Drag isn't men anymore.
It's not just
a concept of drag queens,
it's a drag artist.
So I think that "queen" part
needs to kind of
come out now,
and we just put "artist"
in there
and make it an open term,
just like the word queer.
It's an umbrella term.
Like, what is drag,
do you know what I mean?
It's art.
It's just a bit of fun.
So why does it have to be
staggering to just men?
My name's Brent Would,
W-O-U-L-D,
because I would anything,
literally, especially you.
Well, I've been dancing
since the age of three.
That's what I started off
doing: tap, ballet, jazz.
and singing, because
my family were publicans
in Wandsworth
and Battersea.
So we're quite a theatrical
family as it is.
And then,
probably about 2016,
I took part
in the Man Up competition
for drag kings,
headed up by Adam All
and Apple Derrieres,
who are absolutely fantastic
community leaders
and performers.
Uh, and so, yeah, that was
where I really got into…
into "drag king-ing",
I should say.
What I find challenging
about drag is
when I've been booked
on line-ups
and I definitely feel
like I'm there
as a tokenistic gesture.
I feel sometimes that I'm
in these environments
whereby I have to try
and perform
in a way that other people
want me to,
and I don't get
the same reception.
So, I used to do stand-up
for years, just…
not in drag.
And often
I would get introduced
as, um, a female comedian,
which often puts you
on the back foot,
because people are, like,
"Mm, what you gonna do?"
And then, like, if you fail,
you fail for every woman.
Drag kings are
at the forefront
of the radical nature
of drag.
But drag in and of itself
is like a radical,
political act, right?
And, you know,
just at Stonewall
when it was a trans woman
who was at the front
and lesbians that were,
like, very key,
again, people have been
sidelined.
And I think
we shouldn't forget
that there's
an entire community of drag
that we're not seeing
represented
in the mainstream media.
I want to be able to perform
to audiences who have never
seen a drag king before.
I think that's amazing.
First of all, like,
I… I remember the first time
I saw my drag…
first drag king
and drag queen,
not at the same time.
But it's a really fun, like,
experience, you know?
What is this, you know?
I want to tell people that,
you know?
And just spread the…
the word that there's more
than just drag queens
out there.
There's, like, all kinds
of different drag creatures.
It's just kind of getting
gender equality here.
It's like, well, why is it
that we can't do
the same as drag queens?
You know?
When I started drag,
like, 14 years ago nearly,
yeah, oh my God, 14 years,
uh, it was kind of… it was
a very underground art form.
We were the kind of weirdos
of the scene.
You know, we did drag.
Everyone loved us
in the bar,
but then in the day,
no one knew who we were,
which was kind of nice
because you have
this kind of alter ego.
But at the same time,
you know, nobody wanted
to date a drag queen,
nobody wanted to be friends
with a drag queen.
But now, drag is everywhere.
It's all over the TV,
it's in theatres,
there's brunches,
there's bars.
I mean, it is everywhere.
You know, a lot of Drag Race
fans will have never heard
of Lily Savage, Danny
La Rue, Charles Pierce,
Jimmy James,
legends of drag.
And there is kind of a…
I don't want to say,
like, a wall
between older drag queens
and younger drag queens.
It's very slight.
But sometimes,
I'm… it's just happening.
You know, things…
things blow up
and underground things
become mainstream.
So I came up
with the name Stacey Recht
because I always
found myself funny.
Not to be big-headed, but I
do find myself hilarious.
And I was searching
on the internet one day
for, like, pun names,
and it come up and it just,
like, shone out to me.
And I thought, "That is me.
I am Stacey Recht."
So, I am 20 years old.
I've been doing drag
for two years.
Um…
Half of it was spent
during, like, the pandemic
and the lockdowns,
but, um, I used that time
to, like,
just to focus on my craft.
Like, I learned how to sew.
I learned, you know…
I learned more makeup skills
to make myself
look even prettier.
I'm a queen for photos.
Like, I love memories
that you can hold,
like this photo.
Um, I've got a signed photo
of The Vivienne.
It's a special place
in my heart
because it was
the first ever gig
I ever did outside
of my hometown.
And I had to win
a drag competition
just to, like, open for her.
And I remember meeting her,
and I was like, transfixed.
I was, like, "Wow.
Like, she won Drag Race."
I was just, like, so in awe.
And she was so lovely
and so, like, humble.
And I had my crown on
from winning the competition
and she was, like,
"Congratulations
on your win."
I was, like,
"Congratulations
on yours, too.
Your crown's probably
a lot better than mine."
Being from a small town,
you've got
to fight that hard…
Like, you've got
to fight harder
for the opportunities.
Problems or, like, hardships
that come with drag
is, like, money.
Like, I spend, like,
every penny that I make in…
going into, like, my drag.
Everything gets funnelled
back into Stacey.
And sometimes, like,
Lewis, like, as a boy,
gets left out because
I put her to the front.
But she is the one
that makes the money.
And it's trying to find
that, like, that balance.
Some queens just don't
have the funds to, like,
get extravagant, like,
extravagant costumes,
like, you know.
Some of them have to resort
to, you know, wearing, like,
a £5 dress from,
like, Primark or stuff.
And
what winds me up is, like,
people see, like, Drag Race
and see these amazing
outfits and they think,
"Oh, so all drag queens
should wear that."
And it's, like, "No.
That's what you should wear
on Drag Race."
Like, I know Veronica
mentioned on Instagram
after her Drag Race
elimination
how, like, she was
struggling for money
after… because
of the Covid pandemic,
and then having to do
season 2, then season 3.
Like, just trying to find
the funds and stuff.
And I think people forget
the money that goes into it.
And they also forget, like,
the… just the pure work,
like, that goes
into getting into drag.
Like, people think you only
work, like, five, six hours.
But I do, like,
12 hours a day
just coming in
and getting ready
and then getting
out of drag.
Like, I spend more time
in this dressing room
than I do
at my own house sometimes.
But I wouldn't trade it
for the world.
I honest… Honestly, I
don't know what I'd be doing
without drag, like.
I'd say drag saved my life,
because before drag,
I was a bit lost,
but now I feel
like I've got a purpose.
Now, guys.
We have had
the pleasure of having
one of the most
fabulous divas of Hull
join us tonight.
Stacey Recht!
Make some noise for Stacey!
Drag Race UK has created
opportunities
for queer performers
and for drag artists
that never existed before.
It's a very…
It's done an amazing
and a wonderful thing.
And I'm so excited
to see that
that door is now opening
to female-identifying
performers,
to AFAB queens,
to trans queens.
It's wonderful to see
that happening as well,
because that diversity
has always been
in our scenes.
Um, I think
what comes with that,
and what always comes
hand-in-hand with that,
is that you have one hell
of a lot more people
doing drag.
And in many ways,
the way that you see drag
working now in the UK,
it resembles the wider model
of reality television,
and then the wider model
that we have in our society
of even unregulated,
free-market capitalism.
You know what I mean?
The people at the very top,
the people
at the apex of the pyramid,
become the incentive
for all of those people
who you have
creating art underneath.
And whilst that is
a great thing
that it becomes
an incentive to create,
you're gonna have a lot
of people disappointed.
And so whenever
I meet new drag queens,
and they…
people ask me, like,
"What is
your big tip for drag?
How do I become
successful in drag?"
I always say,
"Have something else."
For two reasons:
you'll need to survive,
and not everybody can be
on the show.
Not everybody
can make it big,
and that's the way
that it's set up.
But also, because it makes
your drag more interesting.
Hull, make some noise
for the superstar
that is Miss Stacey Recht!
Isn't that exciting?
Sorry, I did that thing
where I looked
at the camera.
Is that gonna be awful?
Stacey, give me a clap
in front of your face,
would you?
I'm a proper director now.
What's the future of Polo
Lounge? Another 25 years.
That's what I hope.
Even more.
That's my biggest hope, that
it stands for a long time
and that it constantly moves
with the times
and it constantly
updates itself
and it constantly keeps
regenerating,
because that's
where queer venues
need to focus on right now,
is the constant change
that's happening.
When it comes
to new pronouns
and all this kind of stuff,
you need to stay up to date.
You can't stay in the past.
Like, you need to walk
with the community.
I really hope that Polo
continues to do that
and creates a safe space
for a long time to come.
At its heart,
drag is queer expression.
It's not meant to be
necessarily palatable.
It's not meant
to be beautiful or, um…
It's not…
it's not meant to, in a way,
please straight people.
What I think really
characterises UK drag
is that anarchic, punk,
pantomimic sense.
I feel
like we're not always
polished, look-wise.
So I think that performance
and comedy
and not taking yourself
too seriously,
but quite a punky nature,
is the heart of UK drag
for me.
We're queer storytellers.
Our history comes from being
in a marginalised community.
Our purpose, if you like,
is to amplify,
um, people
who are not amplified.
Drag Race and…
It… It's given us a platform
that we can either
sit on and enjoy
or we can invite
other people onto it,
and other people
can use that as well.
Drag Race queens are
very little, really.
We've had three seasons
in the UK.
What's that, 30 queens?
There's plenty room
for everyone else.
I think the general public
have a more expansive view
about what drag is,
who can do drag
and all of that.
Shoutout to Victoria Scone,
changing the world.
I think the idea of drag
being this stale, kind of,
"dressed-as-a-girl",
only drag queens
kind of idea
is something that
maybe existed in the past.
But as we go forward,
I think we're gonna start
seeing
way more playing around
with not just, like,
femininity, but masculinity,
gender-blurring,
gender queer, kind of,
gender fluid identities.
Um, so many performers
are non-binary, you know,
and that's a really integral
part of, like, who they are
and how they express
themselves.
And so I think
it's just gonna kind of go
in all directions.
It is punk rock.
It is political.
It is about, um,
questioning the status quo
and standing up
to heteronormative values
in our world.
Um, I think if we lose that,
drag will kind of lose
its meaning.
So I hope that
that is always remembered
as drag continues to grow
and take over the world.